Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Ich bin Markus. Ich moderiere normalerweise das
Chaosradio, aber das findet ja jetzt immer im Wechsel mit Dicke Bretter statt.
Und in Dicke Bretter soll erklärt werden, wie Gesetze und politische Initiativen
zu digitalen Themen entstehen und wie Institutionen arbeiten,
in denen Regeln, Urteile oder auch Regulierungen gemacht werden.
Man könnte also so ein bisschen sagen, während das Chaosradio oft genug fragt,
wer hat jetzt schon wieder genau was angezündet und wie löschen wir das,
geht es in Dicke Bretter eher darum,
wer eigentlich die ganze Zeit Holz produziert und das fein säuberlich zu einem
Scheiterhaufen aufstapelt.
Dicke Bretter ist ein Podcast in Kooperation mit Netzpolitik.org von und mit
Elisa Lindinger, Elina Eickstedt und Konstanze Kurz, der mit Unterstützung des
Chaosradio-Teams produziert wird.
Dieses Mal ist Arne Semstrott zu Gast, den ihr vielleicht von Frag den Staat kennt.
Es geht darum, wie man jahrelang aktivistische Projekte betreibt, ohne zu verzweifeln.
Und er verrät auch, wie es um die Informationsfreiheit in Deutschland bestellt ist.
Music.
Wir begrüßen euch ganz herzlich zu einer neuen Folge Dicke Bretter,
diesmal in voller Besetzung mit Besuch.
Ich bin Elina Eickstedt und ich bin hier zusammen mit Elisa Lindinger. Hallo.
Hallo, ich bin Constanze Kurz und wer bist du?
Ich bin Arne Semsrott. Hallo. Wir freuen uns heute sehr, Arne hier zu haben
und ich hatte die Ehre, das erste Mal in meinem Leben etwas über Arne zu recherchieren.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen komisch gefühlt. Das erste, was man findet,
ist Bruder von Nico Semsrott. Das ist in der Google-Schecke.
Es scheint die offizielle Beschreibung zu sein. So stelle ich mich auch immer
vor, wenn ich gefragt werde. Ja, ich habe das auch, meine Schwester.
Ja, aber man kennt dich ja eher so aus Songs wie Fragen, Klagen,
Haben oder das ist alles von der Informationsfreiheit gedeckt und darüber wollen
wir heute auch so ein bisschen sprechen.
Wir haben uns ja in den letzten paar Folgen ein bisschen mehr Theorie angeguckt,
wie funktionieren solche Gesetze eigentlich,
wann kann man irgendwie eingreifen und ich glaube Arne ist eigentlich dafür
bekannt, das System so ein bisschen von innen zu zerstören oder alternative
Wirklichkeiten zu entwickeln.
Und deswegen sind wir sehr gespannt, was du zur aktiven Gesetzesbekämpfung sagen
kannst, hätte ich was gesagt. Sehr schön, danke für die Einladung.
Haben wir was Wichtiges vergessen bei deiner Vorstellung? Würdest du da was hinzufügen?
Genau das, was soll man sonst sagen. Also ich arbeite vor allem an Frag den
Staat, so seit zehn Jahren inzwischen tatsächlich.
Da geht es um Informationsfreiheit, um so ein paar Themen in dem Zusammenhang,
da reden wir gleich sicher noch drum.
Vielleicht kannst du kurz vorher einmal sagen, was Informationsfreiheit ist.
Informationsfreiheit ist das Recht auf Zugang zu Informationen.
Ein Grundrecht, ein Menschenrecht, das wir alle haben. Und das ist in Deutschland
und in anderen Ländern über Gesetze geregelt.
Und die bieten uns die Möglichkeiten, alle möglichen Infos vom Staat zu holen.
Also alles, was so in Aktenschränken liegt und verkümmert teilweise,
das können wir besorgen.
Oder wir können zumindest versuchen, es zu besorgen. Und das ist dann häufig ein ganz schöner Kampf.
Was gibt es noch zu dir zu erzählen? Ich arbeite auch am Freiheitsfonds.
Das ist ein Projekt, bei dem wir Menschen aus dem Gefängnis freikaufen.
Jedes Jahr sind zwischen 7.000 und 10.000 Menschen im Knast,
weil sie ohne Ticket Bus oder Bahn fahren und dann eine Geldstrafe bekommen.
Und das sich nicht leisten können. Also weder das Ticket zuerst,
noch die Geldstrafe, die sie bekommen.
Und das führt dann dazu, dass vor allem Menschen, die kein Geld haben,
also kein Geld überhaupt für ein Ticket, letztlich im Knast landen und wir kaufen
diese Menschen frei und kämpfen damit für eine Entkriminalisierung von Fahnen
ohne Ticket. Und das läuft auch ganz gut.
Wir wollen ja jemandem sagen, wo wir sind, weil möglicherweise ja irgendwelche
Leute 2037 diesen Podcast hören.
Und wir sind also gerade Anfang April und die sollen wahrscheinlich irgendwann im April rauskommen.
Und heute kam gerade eine gute Nachricht aus Köln, die hast du wahrscheinlich schon gehört.
Köln wird nicht mehr diese Leute zur Anzeige bringen, die sie aufschnappen.
Das heißt, ihr habt, oder ich bringe das Beispiel mit Köln nur,
weil ihr ein paar Erfolge habt, die einfach sozusagen über die PR und das Projekt
und auch den politischen Druck.
Also vielleicht nicht im Großen, aber einen kleinen Erfolg gehabt.
Würdest du das so unterschreiben oder ist das eher die Ausnahme?
Also beim Freiheitsfonds bin ich selbst Ich bin selbst beeindruckt davon,
wie gut dieses Projekt funktioniert, ehrlicherweise.
Ich meine, ich mache seit sehr langer Zeit schon so Zeug und jedes Mal,
bevor wir irgendwie so was anfangen, denke ich, ach, das interessiert auch niemanden
und das funktioniert doch nicht und alle sagen, ja, tolle Idee,
aber das wird doch eh nix.
Und bei dem Projekt ist das wirklich eingeschlagen und das fand ich interessant,
weil es so anders ist als viele andere.
Also Leute einfach aus dem Gefängnis freizukaufen, das ist irgendwie so klar.
Und das ist von der Botschaft auch so eindeutig, dass dieses Thema,
was eigentlich seit, ich glaube 30 Jahren im öffentlichen Diskurs…,
Was klein ist, also diese Forderung nach einer Entkriminalisierung,
die gibt es seit Ewigkeiten.
Das Gesetz, dass das eine Straftat ist, ohne Ticket zu fahren, das gibt es seit 1935.
Das haben die Nazis eingeführt. Das ist jetzt alles nichts Neues,
aber es brauchte halt so eine andere Herangehensweise, um es in den öffentlichen
Diskurs zu geben. Und das ist nichts Neues?
Das würde ich aber ja nicht unterschreiben. Ich glaube, dass viele das einfach
überhaupt nicht wussten. Also ich glaube, du hast es ins Bewusstsein geholt
oder ein bisschen geboxt.
Also es war ja durchaus auch eine sehr provokative Art, oder?
Insofern ist der Erfolg doch auch
besonders cool. Ja, und es war viel konfrontativer eigentlich ausgelegt.
Also ich dachte, wir starten das.
Wir haben das ja ursprünglich auch tatsächlich zusammen mit dem ZDF Magazin
Royale so an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht, die ein bisschen zurückhaltender waren
mit dem Freikaufen, weil naja,
Justizjahre vom ZDF sind da ein bisschen zurückhaltender als wir es sind.
Deswegen ist das auch eine eigene Organisation, die unabhängig von denen ist.
Aber die Idee war eigentlich, wir starten das, wir kaufen Leute aus dem Gefängnis
frei und dann war meine Vermutung, da gibt es eine große Kampagne dagegen, wie können die nur?
Also wie können denn hier Leute, die im Gefängnis landen, einfach so rausgeholt werden?
Und das Gegenteil ist aber passiert. Es gab wahnsinnig viel Rückendeckung,
inklusive der CDU-Justizminister von Nordrhein-Westfalen, der gesagt hat,
der ist doch super, wenn sie frei kaufen, die Leute. Die gehören eh nicht ins Gefängnis.
Und da gab es dann auf einmal so eine breite Unterstützung dafür,
sodass halt ja inzwischen die meisten Anfragen, die wir bekommen,
von Gefängnissen kommen.
Also wirklich von Gefängnisleitungen, von MitarbeiterInnen von Gefängnissen,
die uns sagen, hey, könnt ihr uns bitte die Leute freikaufen?
Und das ist ja wirklich absurd. Also überhaupt zu sehen, wie breit die Unterstützung
dafür ist, damit hätte ich überhaupt nicht gerechnet, weil ich dachte,
das wird ein provokatives Hau-drauf-Projekt und dann schaffen wir es über so
eine Polarisierung, das Thema an die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen und stattdessen
ist das so ein Projekt geworden,
das alle toll finden und das ist toll.
Auch überraschend. Das ist jetzt so ein sehr konkretes Beispiel,
wo ihr ja auch so in ein Gesetz reingegriffen habt, sage ich mal,
was schon sehr lange besteht, wo man irgendwie drüber gestolpert ist,
sage ich mal in Anführungsstrichen wahrscheinlich.
Und jetzt sozusagen so von innen heraus auch nochmal ab Absurdum führt,
was da eigentlich los ist.
Normalerweise oder ich glaube so wie ich Frag den Staat auch kennengelernt habe,
seid ihr ja auch irgendwie generell die Plattform oder kann man ja nicht sagen,
dass ihr das seid oder die Community, die Leuten oder Gesetzen auf die Finger zeigt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das besser beschreiben kann.
Und wir haben ja schon super viel so über Gesetzgebung gesprochen in diesem Podcast.
Und ich weiß auch, dass ihr jetzt auch auf EU-Ebene IFG-Anfragen ermöglicht.
Aber wo würdest du so dieses Frag den Staat so auch als Plattform für Personen,
die irgendwie aktivistisch tätig werden wollen,
einordnen, um im Gesetzgebungsprozess oder auch danach, ich glaube,
das ist so das Besondere.
Wir sprechen ja meistens eigentlich darüber, wie wir es im Prozess beeinflussen
können oder wie wir irgendwas wegbekommen.
Und da gibt es ja sehr viele klassische Mittel, aber ich glaube so IFG-Anfragen
als Aktivismusmittel ist ja dann doch relativ neu gewesen.
Wie würdest du das einordnen? Ja.
Es gibt natürlich auch noch die Frage der Implementierung danach,
da können wir ja auch noch drüber sprechen.
Also das Gesetz ist da und dann ist die Frage, was passiert denn eigentlich damit?
Ich sehe FragDenStaat so als Organisation zwischen allen Stühlen in einer Weise,
als mögliches Mittel für AktivistInnen, für Organisationen Druck zu machen,
sich Infos zu holen, sich bemerkbar zu machen und Kampagnen oder Vorhaben,
die sie haben, zu verstärken.
Also erstmal ist es ja relativ simpel, es gibt diese Informationsfreiheitsgesetze,
über die haben wir die Möglichkeit, Infos vom Staat zu bekommen.
So weit, so gut. Und dann ist aber die Frage, wie kann man das in politischer
Arbeit so einsetzen, dass es auch tatsächlich einen Unterschied macht.
Und da ist natürlich das Offensichtlichste, ich hole mir eine Information,
da steht irgendwas krasses drin. Also was weiß ich, das eine Referat im Innenministerium
streitet sich mit dem anderen Referat im Justizministerium.
Ich kriege das mit, weil ich alle E-Mails zwischen den beiden Häusern abfrage
und kann darüber, wenn ich das an die Öffentlichkeit gebe, Druck machen,
weil ich zeigen kann, das Justizministerium ist eigentlich dagegen und es wird
trotzdem gemacht oder so. Also ein relativ einfaches Beispiel.
So kann man das natürlich einsetzen, indem man versucht, aus so einem Gesetzgebungsprozess
Infos an die Öffentlichkeit zu holen und vielleicht interne Streits nochmal
sichtbarer zu machen. Aber es funktioniert auch ein bisschen subtiler.
Wenn ich eine Anfrage stelle, gerade in laufenden Prozessen und die vielleicht
auch spezifisch stelle,
dann merken die Behörden das und merken, dass Leute im Apparat und haben einen mehr auf dem Schirm.
Also wenn ich dann im, um jetzt bei dem abstrakten Beispiel zu bleiben,
wenn ich da jetzt im Innenministerium das Referat anfrage nach den bestimmten
Infos, dann wissen die, okay, der hat Ahnung davon und der bleibt da offensichtlich auch dran.
Ich muss jetzt mal Acht geben, was ich hier überhaupt in die Akte reinschreibe.
Das heißt, das ändert dann schon mal Prozesse oder zumindest haben die einen
dann auf dem Schirm und das kann ja dann schon mal was ändern,
wenn die wissen, dass da jemand drauf schaut.
Und wenn ich dann eine Info vielleicht auch nicht bekomme, es gibt ja zahlreiche
Ausnahmetatbestände im Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, die Dinger sind überhaupt
verbesserungswürdig, aber auch wenn ich eine Ablehnung bekomme,
kann ich das für Kampagnen gut nutzen, weil ich dann sagen kann, guck mal,
die haben diesen Gesetzgebungsprozess, aber die geben die Infos nicht raus.
Offensichtlich haben die was zu verbergen und dann kann man natürlich mit sowas
oder auch mit geschwärzten Akten gutes Campaigning machen.
Also es ist teilweise tatsächlich so, dass Infos, die sie nicht rausrücken,
interessanter sind als Infos, die sie rausrücken.
Manchmal ist es total langweilig, was man bekommt und man wünscht sich eigentlich,
dass sie sagen, kriegt ihr nicht, damit man damit an die Öffentlichkeit gehen
kann und sagen kann, aha.
Offensichtlich ist das alles ganz prima. Ich erinnere mich noch,
meine erste IFG-Anfrage über FragDenStaat war in der Kampagne Top Secret und
das fand ich war nochmal so ein drittes Beispiel,
wie ihr da ganz gut wirkt, nämlich, dass es jetzt weniger darum geht,
wie soll ich sagen, auf eine parteipolitische Agenda zu kommen oder quasi so
hoch aufgehängte Themen zu besetzen oder auch die in den Vordergrund zu schieben.
Sondern es ging ja stärker darum, ein Datenbestand, der bisher nicht einsehbar
war, nämlich konkret die Gutachten von Gesundheitsämtern, richtig,
zu Restaurants, wo wir alle gerne hingehen und essen und vielleicht auch mal
ganz gerne wissen wollen würden, wie es in der Küche aussieht,
um diese Gutachten frei zu kriegen.
Und solche Kampagnen habt ihr früher relativ oft gemacht. Und gefühlt wird das
jetzt weniger. Täusche ich mich da?
Oder was ist deine Bewertung inzwischen von dieser Vangelize?
Das stimmt und es gibt sehr konkrete Gründe, das kann ich gleich sagen.
Genau, bei Top Secret geht es um diese Lebensmittelkontrollberichte und bei
denen war das ganz interessant,
dass wir es glaube ich mit dieser Kampagne geschafft haben, erstmal egoistische
Motive von einzelnen Leuten zu einer Kampagne mit einem höheren Ziel zusammenzufassen. Ja, total.
Und zu mir, also ich gehe in ein Restaurant, danach habe ich einen verdorbenen
Magen, dann will ich erst mal sehen, war das Hygieneamt eigentlich da und vielleicht
haben die ja Hygieneprobleme und deswegen ist bei mir dann irgendwie privat das Magenproblem da.
Und es haben jetzt glaube ich 60.000 Leute tatsächlich Lebensmittelkontrollberichte
über die Plattform angefragt, aus ihren eigenen Motiven.
Und das aber zusammengenommen ergibt dann eine Kampagne für mehr Transparenz
in dem Bereich, weil wir natürlich sehr gut sagen können, offensichtlich wollen
so viele Leute das wissen, dann wäre es doch viel einfacher,
diese Infos von sich aus zu veröffentlichen.
Also das war immer die Forderung, die wir mitkommuniziert haben.
Aber das tun die aber, die hängen ja nur auf Papier in den Ämtern.
Also die veröffentlichen die ja, nur dass man die nicht online haben kann, right?
Ja, es kommt dann auch nochmal auf die Bundesländer an, die machen es unterschiedlich.
Aber das Ziel, was man natürlich eigentlich haben will, ist so ein bundesweites Gesetz.
Das gibt es in anderen Ländern, so ein Smiley-System, wo dann irgendwie ein
Hygienesmiley draußen am Restaurant
rangepackt werden muss. Und das wäre auch viel leichter für alle.
Man müsste so einen Prozess etablieren. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig.
Neue Prozesse etablieren, immer große Pein. Aber wenn man das erstmal hätte,
wäre das für alle Seiten ganz klar.
Und da haben dann aber letztlich die Verwaltung gesagt und das Ernährungsministerium,
Landwirtschaftsministerium haben gesagt, ja nö, dann ballern die uns halt zu
mit tausenden Anträgen.
Das müssen jetzt die Ämter alle abarbeiten.
Wir machen so ein Smiley-System nicht. Und wir können aber zu den einzelnen
Ämtern hingehen und sagen, macht doch bitte Druck beim Bundesministerium,
damit die ein Gesetz einführen, dann habt ihr auch diese Arbeit nicht mehr.
Sehr klaren, letztlich ja ökonomischen Druck in einer Weise auf die Behörden
dafür sorgen, dass die dann wiederum aus eigenem Interesse für eine Sache lobbyieren.
Das ist so ganz interessant.
Wir müssen das vielleicht mal offenlegen, weil wir das bisher noch gar nicht
gesagt haben. Jetzt hat Elisa gerade erzählt von ihrer ersten IFG-Anfrage,
die ja dann schon, weiß ich nicht, mindestens vier Jahre oder so her ist, wenn Stop Secret war.
Aber wir kennen uns natürlich auch teilweise schon länger. Also mit Elisa hast
du tatsächlich mal gearbeitet in der Open Knowledge Foundation und wir beide
haben auch schon, wir hatten nie zusammen wirklich ein Projekt,
aber wir kennen uns ewig.
So diese Berliner Aktivisten-Bubble ist glaube ich ganz schön klein. Und ich bin zugezogen.
Aber wir wollen das nur mal dazu sagen, dass wir uns teilweise schon einfach
lange kennen und die Projekte auch schon länger beobachten oder selber auch Nutzer sind.
Redest du da eigentlich gerne noch strukturell drüber? Also das hat jetzt so
eine lange Geschichte, das hat sich auch verändert.
Es gibt auch einen ganz klaren Pushback, über den wir glaube ich gleich mal
reden sollten. Der ist jetzt noch sehr aktuell, weil er erst vor ganz kurzer
Zeit war, nämlich das Urteil des Bundesverwaltungsgerichts.
Also hast du da noch dieselben aktivistischen Energien? Sind die eher mehr geworden,
strukturierter geworden?
Oder verlagerst du das auf Dritte? Du bist ja nicht alleine.
Also wie siehst du das so einfach nach einem Jahrzehnt?
Ich glaube, es hat sich so ein bisschen verlagert. Also ich bin auf jeden Fall weniger optimistisch.
Also ich bin deutlich pessimistischer an allem.
Das ist gar nicht unbedingt schlimm, glaube ich. Ich glaube,
das macht die Arbeit auch vielleicht tatsächlich eher besser,
kann ich mir vorstellen.
Wobei manchmal natürlich auch so ein naives Herangehen super ist,
weil man irgendwie denkt, man kann es schaffen und wenn einem vorher klar wäre,
was für eine Arbeit das ist, dann würde man vielleicht gar nicht erst anfangen.
Insofern, Naivität ist eigentlich auch immer ganz schön.
Ähm, naja, aber gerade bei diesen Kampagnen, ähm, die sind tatsächlich,
Elisa hat es gesagt, die sind weniger geworden, weil, ähm, wir mit der letzten
Kampagne, die wir gemacht hatten, ganz schön auf die Schnauze gefallen sind,
also, das ist vielleicht ein großes Wort, aber, ähm, das war.
Das war eine Kampagne, mit der wir die Bundesverwaltung zwingen wollten,
all ihre Lobbykontakte offen zu legen.
Und das war riesig angelegt, viele tausend, letztlich zehntausende Anfragen
nach einzelnen Lobbytreffen. Und die haben die Bundesministerien komplett gegen
die Wand fahren lassen, haben die alle abgelehnt.
Wir haben ganz viel geklagt dagegen und sind letztlich vor den Verwaltungsgerichten
nach drei Jahren oder so angekommen erst. Diese Prozesse sind wahnsinnig lang,
das heißt da war schon mal dann Luft raus aus dieser Kampagne.
Neue Regierung dran, also irgendwie kannst du ja kampagnemäßig auch nicht mehr
machen, so nach drei Jahren kannst du nicht so eine Spannung aufrechterhalten.
Und dann hat die Bundesverwaltung vom Verwaltungsgericht einen ziemlich großen
Sieg für sich errungen, weil die nämlich gut nachweisen konnten,
dass die Fragen nach Lobbytreffen, also wann hat sich Bundesministerin und die
Abteilung XY getroffen mit dem Chemieverband, dass diese Informationen in der
Bundesverwaltung nicht strukturiert vorliegen,
weil deren Aktensysteme einfach scheiße sind.
Die sind wirklich einfach riesige Scheiße.
Liebe Kinder, dieses Wort sagen wir nur zufällig mal im Podcast und ist nicht
für den Alltagsgebrauch. Riesiger Mist.
Also das sind wirklich ganz schlimme, komisch zusammengeschusterte Systeme,
wo dann die Beamten im Gerichtssaal sitzen und dem Verwaltungsgericht erklären,
ja schauen Sie mal, wir haben hier den Chemieverband eingegeben als Suchwort,
dann ist das Programm abgestürzt.
Also tatsächlich so, ja. Unmissbar. Und dann fragen wir nach,
ja aber wie legen Sie denn solche Termine ab, die Dokumente dazu und dann sagen
die, ja gibt es keine Vorgabe zu.
Und dann fragen wir aber, wie können sie denn rausfinden, wer sich getroffen
hat? Ja, müssen wir einzeln nachschauen. Wir müssen uns da halt durchklicken.
Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz gibt da keine Vorgaben zu.
Das heißt, wenn die sich mistig organisieren, intern, dann sagt ein Verwaltungsgericht,
ja sorry, wenn das halt nicht schlecht vorliegt, dann können die das nicht rausgeben.
Und das heißt irgendwie, diese komplett verkorkste Digitalisierung führt dann
dazu, dass man einfach an Infos nicht rankommt.
Und dann fällt halt so eine Kampagne auch auf die Nase. Und das ist aber nochmal
spannend festzuhalten, dass ihr ja bei Frage den Staat eigentlich für die totalen
Grundlagen kämpft, nämlich Transparenz.
Und Transparenz ist ja erstmal in sich selber total wenig wert,
sondern es ermöglicht dann ganz viel.
Kampf für Gerechtigkeit, Einflussnahme
mit den Lobbytreffen zum Beispiel aufzudecken, all diese Geschichten.
Aber wenn es daran schon scheitert, insofern verstehe ich jetzt deinen Pessimismus
vielleicht ein bisschen besser,
dass wenn schon die Grundvoraussetzungen für mehr Mitwirkung,
für auch Verantwortlichkeit nicht erfüllt werden können und dann eben vielleicht auch nicht sollen,
dann haben wir echt noch einen langen Weg zu gehen oder um mal den Titel zu
bemühen, ein wirklich dickes Brett zu bohren.
Total. Und wir haben eben auch eine Regierung, die kein Interesse selbst daran hat.
Und da sind dann schon die Grünen hervorzuheben, weil die in der Opposition
immer für Transparenz gekämpft haben, weil die eben auch aus eigenem Interesse,
weil die in der Opposition kaum an Infos selbst rangekommen sind.
Und jetzt sind sie halt an der Regierung und haben halt Zugriff auf die Infos
und haben jetzt auch aus eigenem Interesse nicht mehr wahnsinnig großen Druck
dahinter, irgendwie diesen ganzen Prozess transparenter zu machen.
Und dann sag mal was zum Ampel, wir sind jetzt über die Hälfte der Legislatur,
sag mal was dazu. Na sehr konkret, die Grünen haben ja wirklich tolle kleine
Anfragen gemacht in der Opposition.
Die haben wahnsinnig viele Infos an die Öffentlichkeit geholt,
gerade so im NSA-Komplex und BND und was weiß ich.
Die Leute, die daran gearbeitet haben im Bundestag, arbeiten da immer noch dran,
aber die stellen keine kleinen Anfragen mehr, sondern die stellen interne Anfragen
an die Bundesregierung.
Das läuft jetzt alles im Koalitionsausschuss intern, kriegen die Antworten genauso
wie vorher, aber die werden alle nicht mehr veröffentlicht. Das heißt,
die arbeiten an ihren Themen, aber die Öffentlichkeit ist einfach außen vor.
Und das stört die Grünen offensichtlich auch nicht besonders.
Also mein Eindruck ist immer, die Grünen sind so wahnsinnig loyal zu dieser
Ampel. Die geben so wahnsinnig wenig Infos raus.
Leute, mit denen man vorher irgendwie ordentlich reden konnte,
die quatschen einfach nicht mehr mit einem, weil sie sagen, ja sorry,
das bleibt jetzt intern bei uns.
Und was Transparenz angeht, gibt es einfach überhaupt keine Veränderung zu vorher.
Wenn, dann ist es schlechter geworden teilweise, weil jetzt der Kanzleramtschef Wolfgang Schmidt ist,
der für Scholz seit 20 Jahren die Leichen im Keller begräbt,
Cum-Ex und haste nicht gesehen und der so natürlich auch auf dieses Thema Transparenz
schaut, weil der ein gebranntes Kind ist.
Und wir haben ja eine Klage am Laufen zum Sondervermögen Bundeswehr,
also diese 100 Milliarden, die beschlossen wurden, kurz nach dem Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine.
Und da gibt es offiziell drei Dokumente zu im Kanzleramt. So eine Entscheidung,
in ein paar Tagen 100 Milliarden Euro dann einfach mal frei zu machen.
Drei Dokumente. Natürlich haben die viel ausführlicher darüber gesprochen,
aber alles wurde nicht mehr veraktet.
Und auch in dem Fall sagt dann das Verwaltungsgericht, ja sorry,
wenn es die Infos nicht gibt, dann können wir auch nichts machen.
Und damit kommt dann so ein Wolfgang Schmidt halt durch, beziehungsweise Olaf Scholz.
Und das hat Merkel vorher sicher auch noch gemacht, aber da habe ich den Eindruck,
dass es jetzt einfach noch einen Ticken krasser geworden ist.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein altes Phänomen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir es in der Merkel-Regierung nicht auch expliziert haben.
Die Frage ist, ob es strategisch ist.
Also im Prinzip hast du es ja schon angedeutet. Das betrifft ja nicht nur das
Kanzleramt, sondern auch die Ministerien. Was wird überhaupt noch verachtet?
Ihr habt ja auch juristisch gekämpft für die Frage, was mit SMS und Messenger
ist und so weiter. Und es ist ja auch eine Realität, dass die Menschen zehn
Jahre jünger sind als in der Regierung von Merkel davor, die benutzen Telefone
anders, ganz offenkundig verakten sie weniger.
Aber ihr habt juristisch da zumindest aus meiner Sicht wenig geschafft.
Total, also im Gegenteil würde ich sogar sagen. Ich glaube wir haben ein paar
Sachen verloren, die eine schlechte Praxis dann auch noch legalisiert haben.
Zementiert, ja. Ja, also genau, SMS jetzt zum Beispiel konkret,
da hatten wir eine Klage gegen das Auswärtige Amt, da ging es um SMS,
jetzt aktuell zur Ukraine und davor von Heiko Maas zu Afghanistan und da saßen
dann die Beamten im Verwaltungsgericht und haben gesagt, ja schauen Sie,
technisch ist das gar nicht möglich mit diesen Geräten SMS zu senden,
offensichtlich ist das nicht passiert.
Und dann sagt das Verwaltungsgericht, ja was ist denn mit eurer internen Anweisung?
Dann holen die die interne Anweisung raus und da steht drin,
man darf keine SMS verschicken.
So und dann sagen alle, ja eine deutsche Verwaltung arbeitet nach Recht und
Gesetz, zack und das war's.
Und jetzt kommt man nicht ran an SMS, weil es sie offiziell nicht gibt.
Klar ist, dass alles per SMS gemacht wird oder Threema oder was auch immer.
Auch klar, ist auch allen klar in diesem Gerichtssaal, aber gesetzlich kommt man nicht ran.
Das heißt das Einzige, was da noch bleibt sind Leaks. Also vielleicht um nochmal
auf Elisas Frage zurückzukommen, sie so sagt, ihr kämpft ja auch so ein bisschen am Fundament,
du hast irgendwann glaube ich mal geschrieben, dass es so ein Geheimrätetum
und so eine Attitude immer noch gibt in der deutschen Verwaltung und dass da
auch irgendwie Wert drauf gelegt wird und man hat natürlich bei den Grünen jetzt
auch so das Gefühl, Das hat auch ein bisschen was mit Macht zu tun,
wie viel Transparenz man haben möchte oder auch nicht.
Und über eine Sachen möchten sie dann doch Transparenz haben,
über andere dann auch nicht. Also es ist sehr...
Selektiv und du hast jetzt auch gesagt, naja, ihr habt auch irgendwie Sachen
zementiert, das war sehr eher zu eurem Nachteil und du bist selber auch so ein
bisschen frustrierter.
Was macht das so für dich mit eurer, ich sag mal, strategischen Ausrichtung?
Also wie geht es eigentlich weiter und vielleicht auch für Menschen,
die selber aktiv werden wollen?
Ich weiß, IFG-Anfragen sind manchmal total frustrierend, weil da total doofe
Antworten kommen, auch wenn man eigentlich denkt, okay, so eine Antwort wäre jetzt echt lustig.
Also wie verändert sich da die Strategie und wie müssen wir da auch irgendwie
weiterhin eingreifen, sage ich mal so.
Also ich glaube, was sich auch für Frag den Staat so ein bisschen geändert hat,
ist, dass wir nicht mehr nur die IFG, also die Informationsfreiheitsgesetzorganisation sind.
Wir stellen Anfragen und fertig, sondern dass wir das als einen Baustein sehen,
inzwischen nur noch innerhalb eines Ökosystems von verschiedenen Methoden und
verschiedenen Organisationen, die ihre verschiedenen Ansätze haben.
Und klar zu machen, dass wir nicht mehr Leuten erzählen, ihr stellt IFG-Anfragen,
dann wird alles gut, sondern sagen, ihr könnt das so und so nutzen und dazu
braucht man dann so und so eine Kampagne, damit das was bringt.
Und wir machen als Frag den Staat eben teilweise dann auch Sachen,
die ein bisschen weiter entfernt sind von IFG.
Also es läuft jetzt gerade ein Strafverfahren gegen mich zum Beispiel wegen
der Veröffentlichung von Dokumenten in Bezug auf die letzte Generation.
Da gibt es ein Strafverfahren, die sind ja möglicherweise bald eingestuft als
kriminelle Organisation.
Und ich, und ich muss ich sagen und nicht wir in dem Fall, weil das Strafverfahren
gegen mich läuft und die Organisation gemeinnützig ist und deswegen die Organisation
praktisch hat nichts damit zu tun hat,
deswegen habe ich diese Dokumente veröffentlicht.
Und das ist ein Strafverfahren jetzt gegen mich, also die Veröffentlichung von
Dokumenten aus laufenden Strafverfahren wiederum und jetzt auch gegen mich ein Strafverfahren.
Das ist eine Straftat, kann mit einer Freiheitsstrafe von bis zu einem Jahr
geahndet werden und das ist dann natürlich nicht mehr IFG, das hat nichts mehr damit zu tun,
aber das ist immer noch der breite Komplex des Zugangs zu Informationen und
dann ist eben unser strategisches Mittel in dem Fall sich verklagen lassen und schauen,
was so ein Strafverfahren denn eigentlich an Klärung bringen kann.
Im Idealfall führt dieses Verfahren, was glaube ich ganz gut so aufgesetzt haben,
dazu, dass diese Norm für verfassungswidrig erklärt wird.
Was jetzt aber auf jeden Fall schon passiert ist, dass wir eine Fachdiskussion
haben, die ziemlich kontrovers ist, wo auf jeden Fall beleuchtet wird,
dass die Strafnorm, um die es
geht, in dem Fall heißt die 353d im Strafgesetzbuch, dass die Grütze ist.
Da sind sich eigentlich schon mal alle einig, das heißt wir haben da schon mal
einen ganz guten Push hinbekommen Richtung möglicher Gesetzesreform.
Ich glaube, das zeigt auch so ein bisschen die, naja, dass du dich ja auch persönlich
damit einbringst, aber das ist glaube ich auch ein anderer Baustein von dem,
was du jetzt so als Ökosystem beschrieben hast.
Man merkt ja noch was anderes deutlich. Ihr schreibt anders.
Ihr schreibt deutlich journalistischer. Ihr habt eine Zeitung,
hallo? Nein, das fragt den Staat Druckerzeugnis. Genau.
Ihr schreibt auch trotzdem immer noch,
also das ist schon wertend, also ihr bemüht euch irgendwie nicht aufgesetzt
sachlich zu klingen, sondern wenn man merkt, ihr findet eine Entscheidung falsch oder eine Richtung,
die politisch geht, nicht korrekt, dann drückt ihr das auch wirklich so aus,
dass sie da steht. Kommt immer drauf an, wer Autor ist im Blog.
Genau, aber ihr habt auch professionellere Autoren, würde ich sagen.
Also Leute, die auch Aktivisten sind, aber auch journalistische Erfahrungen
haben und noch andere Buchautoren außer dir.
Du hast auch ein Buch geschrieben, zu dem wir noch kommen wollen.
Also es wirkt auf eine starke Weise professionalisierend.
Also noch viel mehr, als so ein bisschen diese Kurve schon die ganzen Jahre ging.
Und ich würde eigentlich gerne wissen, ob es nur an den Menschen hängt oder
ob es wirklich die Absicht war.
Soll das die Weiterentwicklung dieser Plattform sein? Auch so ein bisschen anschließend
an Kallisis Frage, wohin geht das denn?
Ja, ich denke schon. Also da haben wir viel gelernt von Netzpolitik.org tatsächlich.
Ah, das haben wir jetzt nicht gesagt.
Früher hat Arne ab und an für Netzpolitik auch geschrieben, eigentlich viele
Jahre, kann man das sagen? Ja, ja, ja. Sieben Jahre oder so?
Und immer wieder zur Informationsfreiheit, zum Transparenzgesetz?
Und jetzt habt ihr aber eigentlich, ja dadurch, dass ihr selber so publizistisch
stark seid in dem Feld, macht ihr das gar nicht mehr?
Ihr habt eher Kooperationen mit anderen Medien sonst oder schreibt das selber?
Genau. Wir versuchen eigentlich tatsächlich alles, was wir machen,
immer als Kooperation zu machen.
Also sowohl die journalistischen Recherchen immer mit anderen Medien.
Das hat so zwei Wirkungen.
Das eine ist, dass wir versuchen, die anderen Medien damit zu infiltrieren.
Also irgendwie unsere Art zu arbeiten, mehr den anderen näher zu bringen und
das funktioniert auch ziemlich gut, dass die dann nach so einer Recherche, wenn sie denn gut war,
dann vielleicht selbst so Anfragen stellen und selbst irgendwie ähnlich transparent
arbeiten, wie sie es vorher mit uns dann gemacht haben.
Und das andere ist, dass wir natürlich eine Reichweite in Zielgruppen bekommen,
die wir sonst nicht bekommen.
Also so in der netzpolitischen Bubble, glaube ich, sind wir sowieso stark.
Das kommt einfach so aus der Geschichte von Frag den Staat.
Aber dann so in andere Communities zu kommen, wo man vielleicht vom IFG und
von Frag den Staat noch nicht gehört hat, das versuchen wir dann über solche Kooperationen.
Und das gleiche auch mit unseren Kampagnen, das versuchen wir immer mit anderen
NGOs zusammen zu machen oder mit anderen sozialen Bewegungen,
um einfach andere Gruppen zu erreichen und nicht nur in unserem eigenen Saft zu schmoren.
Genau, und ich meine, so eine Professionalisierung, die kommt auch einfach mit
einer Größe. Also wir sind jetzt so 20 Leute, das ist schon eine ganze Menge.
Und dadurch können wir einfach nochmal eine größere Breite an Themen bespielen.
Und das kommt dann schon auch aus den Leuten heraus, dass sie dann Bock haben,
das auch besser zu machen, was wir da machen.
Als wenn nur ich da irgendwie rumsitze und irgendwas wütend in den Blog reinschreibe.
Willst du mal ein paar Zahlen sagen? Jetzt hast du ja gesagt,
wie viele Leute ihr seid. Aber wie viele Leute engagieren sich da gerade auf der Plattform?
Also dass man mal so einen Eindruck bekommt, wie viele IFG-Anfragen,
wie viele Antworten, wie viele positive Antworten, wie viele Bereichsausnahmen.
Also gib mal ein paar Einblicke, das muss ja nicht sozusagen auf zehn hinaus stimmen.
Ja, also über Frag den Staat sind jetzt in den letzten zwölf,
dreizehn Jahren 260.000 Anfragen gestellt worden von knapp 120.000 Usern.
Wir haben natürlich so ein paar Power-User, aber in der Regel stellen die Leute
so, ja genau, ein paar davon sind hier im Raum. Ja.
Aber die meisten Leute stellen vielleicht so zwei, drei Anfragen.
Viel einfach auch mit ihrem persönlichen Bezug.
Also Leute haben Interesse an der Verkehrskreuzung, wo gebaut wird oder die
Kita, die irgendwie neu gemacht wird oder so. Und da sind dann viele Anfragen zu.
Erfolgreich ist eigentlich tatsächlich das meiste, weil das meiste auch gar nicht so brisant ist,
sondern so dann im kommunalen verläuft und den Leuten auch wirklich das bringt, was sie wissen wollen.
So, das ist aber in der Regel dann nicht das, was man mitbekommt,
sondern das, was man mitbekommt, sind natürlich die großen brisanten Fälle und
da ist dann auch eh klar, dass die Verwaltung was nicht rausgeben will,
also dann das Sondervermögen Bundeswehr zum Beispiel,
wenn ich so eine Anfrage stelle, weil sie ja vorher schon, okay,
das geht vor Gericht, so, geben die ja nicht freiwillig raus.
Und von diesen brisanten Fällen, da muss man in der Regel klagen.
Also wir gewinnen auch die meisten Fälle vor Gericht.
Eine häufige Konstellation ist tatsächlich auch, dass wir klagen und dann die
Behörde merkt, ah okay, die meint es ernst und dann geben sie es raus.
Das heißt, es braucht gar nicht erst eine Verhandlung.
Und auch die meisten Sachen in erster Instanz, so Verwaltungsgericht, das gewinnen wir.
Nur die ganz großen Fälle, und das sind die, die du vorher angesprochen hattest,
also SMS und solche großen strategischen Fälle, die die also durch alle Instanzen
gehen, die dann in Leipzig landen beim Bundesverwaltungsgericht,
die verlieren wir fast alle.
Und da sitzen aber auch die konservativsten Richter. Jetzt hast du das wiederholt,
wird eher im Blog geschrieben. Hast du nicht ultrakonservativ geschrieben?
Also naja, man kann ja mal den Präsidenten googeln vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht
und sich anschauen, was für eine Burschenschaft der ist.
Und das kann man mit anderen Richtern da auch machen. Also es ist tatsächlich gerade auch dieser 10.
Senat, also auch der Präsidentensenat, der ist zuständig für Informationsfreiheit,
der hat sich vor kurzem noch ein paar Zuständigkeiten dazu geholt.
Es gab in diesem Informationsfreiheitsbereich sehr lange die Konstellation,
dass dieser zehnte Senat, der zuständig war,
immer sehr konservativ geurteilt hat, immer alles gegen die Informationsfreiheit
und aber der sechste Senat in Informationsfreiheitssachen sehr progressiv geurteilt
hatte. Warum hatte der 6.
Senat was zuständig dafür? Weil der für den BND zuständig ist und der war auch
zuständig für Presse- und Informationsfreiheit im BND-Kontext.
Sodass findige JournalistInnen, wenn sie eine Sache geklärt haben wollten,
gegen den BND geklagt haben.
Da bist du eh in erster Instanz beim Bundesverwaltungsgericht,
die niederen Verwaltungsgerichte, die dürfen nicht an den BND ran,
wenn man gegen den BND klagt, ist man direkt in Leipzig und wenn man irgendeine
Konstellation geklärt haben wollte,
hat man gegen den BND geklagt, ist dann beim sechsten Senat,
nicht beim konservativen zehnten,
sondern beim progressiven sechsten gelandet, die haben dann gesagt,
ja, alles rausgeben, noch ein bisschen zugespitzt und dann war das halt das
Bundes, ja, also im Vergleich zum zehnten, haben zumindest gesagt,
da muss mehr rausgegeben werden.
Und das hat den 10. Senat so gestört, dass die sich jetzt die Presse- und Informationsfreiheit
in BND-Sachen rübergeholt hat.
Das heißt, die BND-Klage, die wir jetzt haben, die im November, am 7.11.
Verhandelt wird, wird dann vor dem 10. Senat, also vor dem Präsidentensenat verhandelt.
Und da gehen wir davon aus, dass die halt alles zurückdrehen,
was vorher so geurteilt wurde.
Und wenn wir da jetzt aber mal das große Ganze angucken, das finde ich ja schon
spannend, dass du sagst, wir merken oder ihr konkret merkt an der Besetzung
von bestimmten Gerichten, ob die eher in eure Sinne entscheiden oder gegen euch.
Wenn wir ins europäische Ausland gucken und schauen, wie da im Zuge des Rechtsrucks
tatsächlich Gerichte neu besetzt werden, wie sich die ganze Richterinnenschaft
wirklich auch verändert.
In Italien haben wir gerade gesehen, sollen Anwärterinnen für Richterämter auf
einmal eine Art von Psychotest machen, also eigentlich ein Gesinnungstest faktisch,
weil Meloni sogar selber sagte, die Richter sind eher zu links.
Und da kommen wir dann vielleicht zu deinem Buch, denn damit hast du dich auseinandergesetzt.
Was blüht uns denn und was passiert, wenn wir hier in Deutschland auch eine
Art von Rechtsruck spüren werden?
Was heißt das konkret für eure Arbeit?
Also das Buch heißt Machtübernahme und wird am 3.6. Das ist ja schön konkret.
Nicht zur Buchmesse, was ist mit dir los? In der Mitte von der Buchmesse? Naja, am 9.6.
Sind EU-Wahlen und gleichzeitig Kommunalwahlen. Ah, du politischer Hoshi.
In Thüringen, Sachsen und Brandenburg.
Und deswegen ist es glaube ich sinnvoll, da vorher ein Buch rauszubringen,
in dem es um die Frage geht, was machen wir denn, wenn die AfD an die Macht kommt.
Kommt, weil das da glaube ich wirklich, das wird da sehr aktuell und im September
sind, also im Juni sind EU-Wahlen und Kommunalwahlen und im September sind die
Landtagswahlen in Sachsen, Brandenburg und Thüringen.
Das heißt, da können wir von so einer blauen Welle ausgehen,
dass die AfD da einige Gewinne machen wird.
Und die Justiz, glaube ich, ist tatsächlich,
Im Vergleich zu anderen Institutionen des Staates am ehesten lange noch unsere Verbündete.
Also ich, so sehr ich meine Probleme habe mit der konservativen Justiz,
es ist keine rechtsradikale Justiz. Nein, noch nicht.
Bock mehr auf diese ganzen Linken und die wollen jetzt mal durchziehen und mit
der AfD eine Koalition machen, dann hätte auch ein AfD-Justizminister nicht
die Möglichkeiten einfach so alle auszuwechseln.
Also die Richterwahlausschüsse sind relativ stabil.
Es ist gar nicht so einfach, Zuständigkeiten an einem Gericht zu ändern.
Man kann an die Geschäftsverteilungspläne ran, aber das dauert alles und RichterInnen
haben so eine gewisse Unabhängigkeit gegenüber der Verwaltung auch internalisiert.
Die lassen sich da jetzt auch nicht einfach so reinreden.
Das bedeutet nicht, dass die keine blöden Urteile machen.
Also gerade im Migrationsbereich haben ja viele Leute so aus der Justizverwaltung
gesagt, dass das schon echt tough ist, was da so eine Stimmung herrscht.
Also gerade so die Oberverwaltungsgerichte, die für die Grundlagenurteile im
Migrationsrecht zuständig sind, die sind alle schon ziemlich krass drauf.
Also die sind schon Richtung alles abschieben, ein bisschen zugespitzt jetzt natürlich.
Aber trotzdem, wenn es jetzt darum geht, dass eine AfD in Regierungsverantwortung
rechtsstaatliche Institutionen abbauen würde, die würden dagegen halten.
Da bin ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher. Jedenfalls noch beide. Genau.
Auf die können wir nicht vertrauen, dass die das alles aufhalten.
Aber die können es verzögern.
Das ist ja auch nicht ihre Aufgabe, das aufzuhalten.
Aber vielleicht, um dich an der Stelle kurz zu unterbrechen,
also dein Buch hat ja so ein bisschen den Untertitel Eine Anleitung zum Widerstand
und ich meinte vorhin schon so, ja,
IFG-Anfragen ist irgendwie ein Tool, auch für Menschen, die jetzt vielleicht
nicht super politisch aktiv in Form von Kampagnen sind, sich selber irgendwie einzubringen.
Und man hat ja schon so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass das auch für mehr Transparenz
und Selbstermächtigung im demokratischen System sorgt und dass Transparenz ja
auch vielleicht irgendwie so ein bisschen eine Brandmauer ist,
auch um das demokratische System zu schützen, in Anführungsstrichen.
Was ist denn da so dein Blick drauf?
Also wir haben ja, glaube ich, eine unheimliche Politisierung durch die Proteste
und das hält sich ja auch, obwohl wir alle irgendwie Sorge hatten,
dass es sich nicht hält, diese Welle.
Aber es gibt jetzt, so ist zumindest meine Wahrnehmung,
viele Leute, die vorher nicht politisch so aktiv waren, die jetzt sagen,
shit, ich weiß, wie soll ich denn dieses Wort nicht sagen, aber im Zusammenhang
mit Gesetzesapparaten und Nazis darf man das sagen.
Ähm, und was ist da so deine Sicht, was können Menschen eigentlich tun,
um sich da jetzt auch einzubringen und irgendwie diese,
ich finde diese Brandmauer, dieses Brandmauer-Wording immer ein bisschen schwierig und abstrakt,
aber mich sprechen auch viele Menschen an, die sagen, hey ja,
du machst doch so viel politische Arbeit und was können wir denn jetzt eigentlich
machen, was ist so die Einstiegsdroge politischer Arbeit?
Und da würde mich immer interessieren, was so deine Sicht darauf ist.
Also tatsächlich glaube ich, Anfragen zu stellen und das mal auszuprobieren
und so einen Kontakt zur Staatsmacht aufzubauen,
ist eine total gute Übung, um ein bisschen die Angst davor zu verlieren.
Also das habe ich so an mir einfach gemerkt, dass ich am Anfang total unsicher
war im Umgang mit Behörden und dann kommen irgendwie als Antwort Briefe in gelben
Umschlägen und sowas kennt man ja nur,
wenn man irgendwie was zahlen muss oder was falsch gemacht hat oder wenn vom
Jobcenter irgendwie was kommt.
Und das aber zu kriegen und zu merken, naja, okay, ich habe ja ein Recht gegenüber
denen und das kann ich versuchen durchzusetzen und ich kann denen antworten
und die müssen mir antworten, das ist, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Übung im Umgang damit.
Ich glaube nicht, dass uns IFG-Anfragen retten werden vor der AfD,
aber ich glaube, dass die tatsächlich eine gute Einstiegsdroge sein können in
so einem Engagement, um dann zu schauen, was kann ich denn eigentlich kriegen,
was kann ich damit machen.
Und was ich so grundsätzlich, glaube ich, als Gedankenübung interessant finde,
ist sich zu überlegen, was würde ich denn machen, wenn die AfD jetzt an die Macht kommt.
Also wirklich sehr konkret, so eine Konstellation, AfD kommt vielleicht in der
Koalition, in einem Bundesland vielleicht an die Macht.
Was bedeutet das für mich? Was bedeutet das für Leute um mich herum?
Und was würde ich an so einem Wahlabend machen? was würde
ich in den zwei wochen danach machen so was
was würde ich ist es denn drin in dem buch
also ist jetzt ein gedankenexperiment du jetzt machst du hast du es auch drin
ich habe das stimmt dass das macht man bei buch promo weiter führe ich das aus
in meinem buch also die meisten hören wir noch nicht kennen dass ich glaube
es ist ein total wichtiger punkt dieses dieses Angst und Respekt verlieren,
klingt jetzt irgendwie so falsch,
aber vor diesem Verwaltungsmonster, weil ich glaube für viele Menschen ist es
halt so, ja, ich gehe halt irgendwie einmal alle paar Jahre wählen und dann
kann ich eigentlich nichts mehr machen.
Und dann gibt es irgendwie so ein paar ganz tolle Leute mit Superkräften und
die können dann irgendwie mit Politikerinnen reden.
Und deswegen ist das, glaube ich, total wichtig und mach gerne weiter mit deinem
Gedankenexperiment, weil es gibt ja dann natürlich auf kommunalen Ebenen natürlich
Sachen, die man machen kann.
Ja, und auch auf Landes- und Bundesebene und überhaupt.
Also ich glaube, genau sowas etwas einzuüben und es einfach zu machen und auch
jetzt schon zu machen, um es mal gemacht zu haben und um zu merken,
so schlimm ist das gar nicht, ist total wichtig.
Und das ist natürlich, das haben glaube ich viele bei den Protesten gemerkt.
Viele waren ja jetzt zum ersten Mal seit sehr langer Zeit wieder auf Protesten.
Und da zu merken, man kann ja sowas machen und dabei sowas Spaß haben,
krass. Man kann irgendwie da Freundin mitnehmen und dann kann man da eine schöne
Zeit haben und meinetwegen Shampoos trinken auf der Demo, warum denn nicht?
Oder man zornet. Ja, man kann irgendwie tanzen.
Und das politisch machen. Also das irgendwie zu verbinden und einzuüben und
zu merken, ah ja, man kann da irgendwie so eine Praxis finden.
Das gilt genauso für IFG-Anfragen, das gilt genauso für, ich schreibe meinem
Abgeordneten einfach, um das mal gemacht zu haben. Vielleicht kriege ich ja
eine Antwort. Oh, interessant.
Ist das jetzt eine generische Antwort oder eine spezifische?
Und sich da so ein bisschen vorzutasten.
Und das gleiche gilt genauso, glaube ich, für zu irgendwie treffen,
von irgendwelchen Initiativen oder Organisationen zu gehen, um mal zu schauen,
wie das denn ist mit diesen komischen Leuten, die sich da engagieren.
Und am Ende, du hast es ja schon angeschnitten, geht es ja wirklich darum,
dass das ja noch nicht mal ein Akt des Widerstands als solcher ist,
sondern wir nehmen da unsere Rechte wahr, die wir vielleicht gar nicht oft genug nutzen.
Sondern wir haben das Recht zu demonstrieren, wir haben das Recht,
IFG-Anfragen zu stellen, wir haben das Recht zu streiken, wir haben ganz viele
Rechte, die in unserem Alltag bisher vielleicht nicht die ganz große Rolle spielen.
Und das wirklich, diesen Muskel auch zu trainieren, ist doch ein schöner Anfang
und ich bin gespannt auf das Gedankenexperiment dann.
Ich muss dir noch eine Frage stellen, die mir schon immer, also jetzt hast du,
wir haben so ein bisschen, eigentlich war das fast ein bisschen rückblickend, oder?
Was ist denn das fetteste Achievement sozusagen, wenn du jetzt mal zurückguckst
in den letzten zehn Jahren, oder du kannst es auch zwei nennen,
also du musst es nicht irgendwie so Single One nennen.
Was ist denn so, wo du sagen würdest, oh Mann, da hab ich echt mal einen Treffer gelandet.
Da bin ich auch im Nachhinein wirklich stolz drauf. Können mir auch andere vielleicht sogar nachmachen.
Ich vergesse das immer, ich bin so wahnsinnig schlecht bei sowas.
Gibt es nichts, wo du denkst, boah, das ist nachhaltig irgendwie,
weißt du, auch so in dem Sinne von, okay, aber sag nicht Transparenzgesetz, wäre jetzt zu billig.
Also es ist tatsächlich, also es ist so, dass es ein paar Dokumente gibt,
ein paar Praxen, die jetzt öffentlich sind und wo das ganz normal ist.
Also es ist inzwischen total normal, dass die Bundesregierung,
also die Bundesministerien, die Referentenentwürfe, also die ursprünglichen
Entwürfe von Gesetzen veröffentlichen.
Und das war 150 Jahre lang nicht so. Ja, mit Synopsen.
Das ist ein einziges Wunder. Stimmt, das ist echt ein Achievement.
Vielleicht sollten wir das mal erklären.
Vielleicht versteht das nicht jeder,
der jetzt irgendwie diese Gesetzgebungsprozesse oder was nicht kennt.
Wenn standardmäßig die Referentenentwürfe rausgetan wären, dann kannst du sozusagen
diese Genese mehr beeinflussen.
Du musst glaube ich erstmal sagen, was Referentenentwürfe sind.
Also die Vorform von einem Gesetz letztlich, die in Worte gekleidete,
meistens auch schon mit ordentlichen Definitionen ausgestattete,
der Vorschlag für ein Gesetz.
Ich glaube das ist für jemanden, egal in welchem Feld, total egal in welchem
politischen Feld enorm wichtig.
Ich wollte das nur erklärbärmäßig hinzufügen. Ja, also ich meine,
das ist ja auch ein deutsches Spezifikum. Also wenn man sich anschaut,
wie Gesetzgebungsprozesse in den USA laufen, da kommt irgendwie aus dem Kongress
von Abgeordneten ein Gesetz.
Das läuft ja in der Regel in Deutschland nicht so, sondern ein Ministerium macht
halt diesen ersten Entwurf, diesen Referentenentwurf.
Und dass der so lange nicht….
Online zu finden war, bis wir da eine Kampagne zu gemacht hatten,
sondern man erst so einen Gesetzentwurf gesehen hat, wenn das Kabinett,
also irgendwie alle Bundesministerien zusammen diesen Entwurf gemacht haben,
das ist schon tatsächlich was anderes,
weil man jetzt besser nachvollziehen kann, was war die Grundlage,
was hat sich danach geändert, dann kann man besser nachvollziehen,
wer hat wohl darauf Einfluss genommen,
also Interessengruppen oder vielleicht auch schon irgendwelche Parteien mit
ihren Interessen und so besser nachvollziehen kann, wie verändert sich denn ein Gesetz.
Also kollektiv verbindliche Entscheidung für uns alle im Laufe dieses Prozesses.
Genau, das ist jetzt alles öffentlich und das ist schon irgendwie krass,
weil das der große demokratische Prozess ist, der jetzt transparenter ist.
Und wir haben, ja, puh, es ist so schwer, weil glaube ich ganz viel von dem,
was wir angreifen, so irgendwie Kultur und Prozesse betrifft und dann zu sagen,
ja, das läuft jetzt anders als vorher, ist halt nicht so wahnsinnig griffig wie Bäm,
das und das ist passiert.
Ja, aber ich würde sagen, naja, vor drei Jahren ist Franziska Giffey als Bundesministerin
zurückgetreten. Ach, sprich doch bitte nicht Franziska Giffey an,
der kriegt ja gleich wieder, das triggert mich enorm.
Giffey, stimmt, Giffey. Wir müssen mal sagen, wer das ist.
Wirklicherweise 2045, wenn irgendjemand
hört, wird es nicht mal mehr ein Wikipedia-Ticket von ihr geben.
Das war mal die regierende Bürgermeisterin von Berlin, das ist eine SPD-Politikerin und Plagiatorin.
Genau, ehemals Dr. Franziska Giffey, jetzt nur noch Franziska Giffey.
Und die ist zurückgetreten als Bundesministerin, weil herausgekommen ist,
dass sie plagiiert hat und dass es rausgekommen ist, liegt an der IFG-Anfrage über Frag den Stein.
Vielleicht enden wir auf dieser positiven Note. Man kann auch mit IFG-Anfragen
unliebsame Politikerinnen loswerden.
Vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Ich würde sagen, stellt weiter IFG-Anfragen und
traut euch, den Kampf gegen das Verwaltungsmonster aufzunehmen,
damit wir unsere Demokratie und demokratische Prozesse transparenter machen
können und es vielleicht in Zukunft nicht mehr ganz so frustrierend ist,
sich in Policy-Prozesse einzubringen.
Und bis dahin könnt ihr immer schön dicke Bretter hören, weil wir werden natürlich
unser Bestes geben, eben diese furchtbaren Prozesse für euch zu erklären und greifbar zu machen.
Und in diesem Sinne bis zum nächsten Mal. Vielen Dank, Arne.
Danke schön. Danke, Arne.
Music.